[Music]
[Applause]
who's the fairest of them all we're
going to find out by pitching two of the
world's most badass women against each
other and a head-to-head battle first up
it Snow White
don't let the name fool you all the fact
she's been asleep for a long time she
has a solid command of martial arts
including German jujitsu and fencing as
well as the ability to bend the will of
nature to her command she has at her
faculty a number of special attacks
including a leaping nature fists and
rage which increases her overall power
the more she gets attacked
she is also rumored to be nearly
immortal and will tend to sleep off any
mortal wounds on the other side of the
field we have the spirit of the north
Elsa who simply cannot let it go a
grudge that is our ability to magically
control ice is only bested by her temper
and has strong command of muy Thai
boxing her fighting regime is bolstered
by to blistering special attacks freeze
touch and avalanche a vice grip like
attack which is rumored to be
inescapable Elsa is widely considered
one of the most powerful women alive I'm
gonna go with Snow White cuz she's og
also has the advantage although Snow
White's pretty scrappy because she grew
up in the woods Snow White has nothing
on Elsa except for all of her woodland
creatures would like van to her side and
so like I think that would give her a
fighting chance but I legit think Elsa
would kick Snow White's ass like pretty
intensely Snow White had to be like
rescued by Prince she doesn't wield any
sort of weaponry
sounds like else at least has powers
snow I always kind of felt like she had
her head in the clouds you know what I
mean whereas Elsa straight up like
almost killed her sisters well they have
it our fighters are geared up and ready
to go let's see he'll win this royal
battle
[Music]
Nelson starts out with a flurry of
attacks easily blah blah by Snow White
who Perry's plow clinch Elsa has the
advantage here if she can there we go
it's the free touch yeah she's very
shaken up by that left hook but as the
fight progresses snow white becomes
enraged and more powerful she's back
ahead going for the takedown he has a
couple of eyesight elbows to the bone
snow white now with a nice shoulder
throw houses down and Snow White is on
the offense sir
[Music]
Elser is fighting back
she's raising her now snow-white has
launched into a looping nature fest
can also get out the way roll Oh big
blow Snow White has the advantage here
now on the ground going for the rear
naked choke
[Music]
oh but she can't sink it better watch
out Ultra is dangerous on the ground
[Music]
oh no she's gonna evidence this doesn't
look good this could be the end folks
[Music]
go add Snow White is asleep
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]